hey youtubers is Charlie and so much
went down on arrow tonight that we're
gonna have to talk about the
repercussions after I do my top five
moments like normal we have a lot of
stuff that we have to talk about and in
case you didn't know there are only
three episodes left this season I was
actually gonna post a bonus video this
morning but I had a few technical issues
so I'm just gonna post that in a few
hours after I post this video be sure to
subscribe to get it
and leave me suggestions for future
bonus videos I'm gonna be doing three
more one for each final episode of arrow
so careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen the episode yet but let's start
with top five moments number five
Roy flips his [ __ ] on everyone did
anyone else get a Frankenstein vibe with
him lying there on the table
they could have done this during
Halloween and it would have been totally
appropriate I knew that he'd hallucinate
Thea but I was surprised that she told
him to kill her Slade shado
hallucination seems a little more
insidious but I guess it just depends on
what your mind is like before you get
injected with mirakuru in case you don't
remember all the way back to heir to the
demon you know in episode 13 the stuff
that they have him on is just an IV drip
of that venom solution it's just gonna
keep him under until they can fix him in
real life it's actually pretty common
for patients who are at risk for
injuring themselves really badly to be
kept in medically induced comas my
biggest surprise from all this actually
ended up being that sin is not really in
on the team arrow business I kind of
thought that she was Sara's partner in
crime but now it seems like she's more
of a sister like Laurel would be number
four
Sara breaks up with Oliver and then
takes off biggest question was who is
that old friend my first guess was that
it's Slade but I think based on what
happened later in the episode she's
going back to the League of Assassins
I'm actually expecting them to come back
to Starling city before the finale and
just you know run clean up on some of
Slade's mirakuru soldiers so maybe
that's what Sara's comeback moment will
be you know she'll be back in the
darkest hour I did get really worried
though when she was talking about you
know the darkness inside her like not
having a soul it seemed like the writers
were teasing that she might end up dying
or wanting us to think that she might
end up dying there had been so many
other clues that she'd live especially
the writers talking about doing more
birds-of-prey next season that it took
the rest of the episode for me to figure
out what was going on high fives to the
writers though for pulling a bit of a
misdirect with that last scene right now
we only have episode descriptions for
the neck
two episodes and Sarah isn't anywhere in
there so it looks like she's not gonna
be back until the finale hopefully with
the League of Assassins and Rachel Ghul
number three Oliver is out of commission
his leg is totally effed up which is why
he pretty much jumped into Felicity's
arms at the bottom of those stairs who
else got a flashback to last season when
ever he carried her in his arms it was a
nice funny moment and another wise you
know very shocking episode Felicity
always does get the best jokes can you
even fit into those leather pants and
she actually did poked fun at him for
being too heavy
who else left out loud when Oliver was
like where are the drugs I need all of
the drugs and he just downed everything
I think it was barely enough to keep him
from standing without crying whenever
they subdued Roy Oliver's pain you know
with his leg was such a big deal in this
episode I kept feeling like they were
teasing him possibly finding some new
mirakuru to use obviously I don't expect
him to do that because the last sample
that he had he gave to Caitlin snow to
make the cure and even Slade didn't have
mirakuru to give those soldiers he had
to leech it out of Roy but number two
Oliver has a child WTF but I didn't see
the name of the woman so if they wrote
it in the credits please add it in the
comments below we should assume that his
child is once still alive and - in in
Central City they were fuzzy about how
far back that flashback went but I guess
the boy or girl would be between like
six or seven years old now old enough
for a young actor to be cast and have
speaking lines so this is really
important remember when Slade said
there's one more person that has to die
I think that that child is gonna come
back in the finale which is called
unthinkable that's the title
I think he's gonna threaten the life of
his child I'm avoiding pronouns but I
think we're all pretty much expecting a
Connor Hawke situation there's such a
huge place for that story to go in
season three I totally think that said
child will survive and be a part of
whatever ends up happening going forward
you know him living in Central City is
just another perfect opportunity to link
arrow and flash stories and now Oliver
in addition to Felicity has a reason to
go to Central City let me know if you
agree though and my number one moment
Slade kills Moira queen huge WTF but
there were some parts of this that I
expected and there were a few things
about it that really surprised me first
off in my finale predictions video I did
last week I did
predicted Moira would be the one to die
but I didn't think she would die this
way I expected slay to use Felicity and
Sarah or Felicity and Thea or really any
other combination of the younger women
on the show in that twist of I bows you
know making Oliver choose who dies so
remember she never told Oliver that his
child was still alive and - she didn't
have time to tell him that Merlyn was
still alive so obviously they have a few
surprises left for the next couple of
episodes I think they did a really good
job of sending more or less character
off
they gave her a very you know dignified
moment at the end where she chose her
children over her own life and Slade
even called her out on it and gave her
some respect I think that's why he used
the blade to kill her instead of
shooting her in the head and I thought
it was really nice that they gave them
that moment of reconciliation where she
told Oliver yes I know your secret
identity so before we talk about
repercussions and what's gonna happen
based on all these big WTF moments let
me know what your favorite moment was
you know was it Moira queen dying
was it the Connor Hawke teaser or was it
something else the thing that's really
sticking with me right now is Slade's
last line there's still one more person
that has to die so let's talk about what
all this means for the final episodes
first off next week we saw in the teaser
the funeral Oliver can't be found
Slade unleashes his army including
Ravager and brother blood has his big
moment the episode is titled city of
blood so it's a big brother blood
episode so things are gonna get much
much worse before they get better
but like I said I expect Oliver child to
be a plot point before the end of the
season Sara to be back with the League
of Assassins and Merlyn is also coming
back to we're not really sure what he's
gonna do yet you know is he just gonna
try and take fee away or is he gonna try
and help him out obviously I'm really
hoping that he tries to help him out
because seeing Oliver fight with Merlyn
would be pretty cool overall I gave the
episode a solid a they just keep making
things worse and worse for Oliver on
Team arrow and it's only gonna make
their victory that much sweeter in the
finale more than any other show this
year we know with the exception of maybe
Game of Thrones
I think arrow has surprised me the most
with how much fun it's been to analyze
week to week it's a big tribute to the
writers that what they the cast and the
crew have done just lends itself to
heavy analysis and discussion it's just
so much more interesting the other big
thing that I'm really looking forward
that I'm hoping is gonna happen in the
next couple of episodes or maybe in
season 3 is thea to choose a path you
know either follow oliver and pick up a
bow or follow Laurel and just become a
more self actualized you know stealth
member of team arrow I was really happy
to see sin again - I think she'll be
around for the finale again and I hope
that she and Roy end up getting some
more of those Young Justice moments next
season you know where they go off on
missions by themselves that's actually
another thing that I really want to talk
about more when the finale is over you
know then doing odd pairings of
characters in season 3
like for instance Diggle and Thea had a
scene together and we really haven't
seen them get a moment like that in a
long long time it was really good so let
me know in the comments below which
characters would you like to see paired
up in scenes that normally wouldn't get
scenes together like Quentin and Diggle
at a bar just telling hilarious stories
about awful things they did in the past
so like I said I'm posting my bonus
video just in a couple hours after I
post this video be sure to subscribe to
get it
it's gonna be my top 10 team arrow
moments this year just moments when it's
just the team it's gonna be a lot of fun
you can actually click here to get that
I'll update the annotation as soon as
I've posted and you can click here to
get my Q&A video that's posting tomorrow
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys a little bit high fives